I am a repair geek.
I grew up fixing things with my dad;
it was what we did.
We fixed our TV,
we fixed our refrigerator,
we fixed stuff that didn't need fixing.
We fixed our Volkswagen Beetle.
In our home,
if something broke, we took it
as an opportunity to have fun.
We loved the idea and the challenge
of bringing things back to life.
And I still love that feeling,
which to me is just thrilling.
I did it recently.
My laptop was overheating,
I thought it might be the fan,
I ordered a fan,
I put the fan in, I turned it on,
and the fan went "whir"
like, “Yes! That really worked.”
It was a great feeling.
Now I know this kind of repair
probably sounds very old-fashioned,
and I probably look
a little old-fashioned,
but it's much more than saving money.
It's how we keep the things
that we like in use.
It helps us keep things out of the trash.
It helps bring jobs into our communities,
and it can help solve the digital divide.
Now, since 2013, I've been
the executive director
of the Digital Right to Repair Coalition,
otherwise known as repair.org.
Our members do all the Rs:
We repair, we reuse,
we resell and we recycle.
And in doing this work,
I've come to realize
that repair is right now central
to all of our sustainability goals.
If we can fix our stuff a little more
frequently, keep it in use,
we're keeping it out of the front
of the waste stream at the front end.
So we'll have less to process
at the back end.
If we are going to have any control
over our e-waste problem,
we have to talk about repair.
Let me give you a sense of scale.
Back in 2013,
the EPA estimated
that the average US household
already owned 28 digitally-driven
gizmos and gadgets.
It was everything from garage-door openers
and hot tub controls to smart toasters.
If we just do a little math and multiply
28 times are roughly
123 million households,
we come up with a pretty staggering
three and a half billion pieces of e-waste
that don't belong in our landfills,
and they are costly
and difficult to put back as raw materials
if those processes even exist.
When we look a little more closely
at what's even possible with recycling,
I think we've been ignoring
some really ugly truths.
By the time a laptop or a refrigerator
or even an electric toothbrush
gets in our hands,
almost all of the environmental
damage has already been done.
All the costs of mining and refining
and smelting and transportation.
And we don't see these costs
when we go to the store,
and we don't see the human costs
of terrible labor conditions
and exposure to toxic materials.
So even if we can't agree
on how to calculate these costs,
I think we can agree that fixing more
and throwing away less just makes sense.
There's a lot of other advantages
of repairing things
other than just the obvious.
Repair is what lets us keep
our older devices in use,
and it allows a secondary market
for the products that we want to resell.
And secondary markets
are why used equipment is so affordable
because the used seller
has to compete with new.
So if a new gadget is 1,000 dollars,
we expect a pretty big discount
to buy that same item used.
Let's start with 50 percent.
So now we have an affordability capability
that is central to crossing
the digital divide.
We had five million students
that went to virtual school this past year
that didn't have enabling technology.
And that's because parents
and school districts couldn't buy new.
We still have a lot of chip shortages,
and these are going to be
with us for a while.
And I think we have to think very
seriously about doing more repair,
not just to make things last longer
but also to be more resilient
as an economy.
Repair is also a point of entry
for a lot of our engineers and innovators.
I heard Steve Wozniak
speak very recently --
Apple Steve Wozniak --
He spoke very recently
about his growth and development
at a time when he was repairing
things as a kid.
And it was central
to his development as an engineer.
He grew up pretty much
the same time I did,
where repairs were very ordinary.
Consumers were empowered to take
their vacuum tubes to the local store,
plug them in and see if they work
and then buy a replacement on the spot.
And there were lots of options for repair
within the community
to help with the more
difficult challenges.
I think you've probably noticed
that these mom and pop
businesses disappeared
or all but disappeared in our communities.
And it’s not because we don’t want
to fix our stuff,
it's because they were not allowed to buy
the essential repair materials
that enabled them to stay in business.
So if we can back that back
and make it possible
for our local repair shops
to buy parts and tools,
then those businesses will come back
and they will bring back with them
jobs that feed families.
And our nerdy kids will be
able to open things up,
figure out how they work
and become the engineers
and innovators of our future.
Repair jobs, which I mentioned,
they’re great jobs,
and they don't require an advanced degree.
I'll give you an example.
There's a charity
in Minnesota called Tech Dump,
and they take in donated electronics,
and then they hire adults
that are hard to employ,
many of whom coming out
of the criminal justice system.
They train them to make repairs.
They then take the repaired goods,
sell them and use the proceeds
to fund more training.
They’re keeping equipment
out of the waste stream;
they’re bringing good-quality equipment
to their community in a used format;
and they are bringing people out
of poverty and into the workforce.
What's really got me irritated
(Laughs)
is that at this point,
the vast majority of products
on the market today
cannot be repaired by any party
without being totally dependent
on the manufacturer.
And the day the manufacturer decides
they don't want you to fix it,
it's over.
This is a completely artificial problem.
Manufacturers used to provide
comprehensive documentation
and schematics and shipped
it with every product.
It was expected
that you could fix your stuff.
Then once the internet allowed
this documentation to be hosted online,
manufacturers stopped printing,
which made sense
because printing was expensive.
And then somewhere
along the line, somebody said,
"Ah, we need to know
who's using our website."
So they demanded a login.
And then another bright light said,
"Oh, we can charge."
So they put up a paywall.
And then a third bright light said,
"We can't let anybody
have this information at all.
They might compete with us."
And that's where we are today.
We can't get what we need
to fix our stuff.
Now, I can tell you
because I've had a front-row seat,
this trend towards a throwaway economy
is reversing all over the world.
And it's really fun to be able
to tell you about it.
Back in 2014,
we put forward our very first
digital “Right to Repair” bill,
and that became the template
for dozens of other bills.
And this year, we've had 27 states
take up the same legislation.
These bills are starting to pass.
There's been a lot of help
from the Federal Trade Commission
and also the Biden administration,
in saying we really, as a country,
need to be able to fix our stuff,
and we need competition for repair.
It's not just us.
Canada and Australia
have got similar processes underway.
The European Union has put forward
a set of regulations that just took effect
that are limiting the use of adhesives
in the construction of products
because if you can't get into the thing,
you can't fix the thing.
France has yet another idea.
They are requiring manufacturers to rate
themselves on their repairability,
and then they are posting those scores
for consumers to consider pre-purchase.
There are groups forming up
all over the world
that help people repair stuff
even without government
or regulatory change.
You may have seen Repair Cafés
advertised in your community.
That first Repair Café
started in 2009 in Denmark.
There are now over 2,000
official chapters.
There are web sites, YouTube
and a company called ifixit.com
that hosts tens of thousands
of repair tutorials
to help people learn
how to fix their stuff.
Last year,
they recorded 116 million
unique users on their website,
so I think it's pretty clear
people do want to fix their stuff.
So I'm very encouraged by the fact
that our throwaway economy,
the trend is reversing.
And we are going to be able
to fix our stuff.
We're going to be able
to use the things we want
in the way that we want them.
We will be able to cross
the digital divide,
and we will have more jobs,
and we will all get that great
“Yes! I fixed it!” feeling.
So the next time
something around you breaks,
don't take "broken" for an answer.
Go fix something.
(Applause)
Thank you.